jt brubacher with a 450 era
still looking for that first major
league win
hopefully that comes today
and brubacher starts him off with a
strikeout wilson contreras
two-time all-star starting catcher was
able to score
on that rizzo single schwarber trying to
move up
he will and that ball in the dirt that
is uh
all on anticipation right now let's
focus our attention on caratini at the
plate he's the cubs d-h today he's
driven in nine runs let's see if he can
add to that total right now
carratini hits the ground ball right
side base hit past the diving frazier
the cubs are going to get on the board
here comes schwarber to score
hayward motors to third carrottini comes
through
cubs lead one to nothing see they've got
three infielders between second and
third two-two count
on bryant there's the ground ball
to third safe there throw to first he
air mailed it here comes half or rather
kipnis half will move to third
everybody's safe it's two to nothing
and riddle tried to make a play on
kiplinges at third base i think that
just upset the timing of the play it was
a good idea to try to make the tag play
on kidneys but then he
makes a bad throw and the pirates
defensively have been very sloppy in
this game cubs still in good shape with
second third one out
and baez strikes out the first base
unoccupied have to throw them out
helps to be able to have the strikeout
in your back pocket once oh yeah and
again
the good breaking ball by as a free
swinger but you got to get schwarber
obviously
there you go that's great work he
strikes out schwarber
well expertly done by the rookie
brubacher navigates out of any further
trouble
very very glad to bring you jacob
stallings pirates catcher joining us
here on att sportsnet thanks for sharing
some time with us today
no problem guys thanks for having me you
know i always feel like i'm pretty fresh
when i
when i do get to play and and that's
especially for a catcher i mean as you
guys know that's it it's a huge thing to
feel fresh and your body feel fresh so
gonzales what a catch by
hap but that'll still get the run in you
give any uh
father fatherly advice to ryan reynolds
yeah how about that he's already using
the dad's strength one for one as a dad
so he's uh he's already reaping the
benefits but
uh no i mean you know just obviously
really glad to hear that
everything went smoothly and then he got
back baby's healthy mom's healthy
now he just needs to homer you'll get at
least half the credit if he does
i think i'll take as much credit as you
know he wants to give him which probably
won't be very much
and i don't know what you guys call it
but after a hit you know we got
something
that the the butter turn and
if it's a homeowner
jacob stallings called it everybody
dad with a three-run homer yeah
that's what i said shelton said dad
strength
are we looking for chase are we looking
to throw for strike is it a combination
of both well you've got a free swinger
up there
you know i think if you look around the
league strike them out
throw them out all right um
what's a catcher doing running that's
yeah third time in a row
matter is ian half two and two on him
moran holding kippness at first
caratini's a runner at third and ouch
oh man foul ball that came back
up and clipped him i believe in the
forehead
i don't know if he got cut by the helmet
but he is down
i think the ball got him i think it
might be his eye
guessing he's going to try to stay in
got to make sure that
he's got clear vision out of that eye
yeah you don't want to be standing in
there facing 95
on our heater with blurred vision yeah i
don't think he can
continue so it's like cameron mabin will
finish this a b
second and third for the pirates and
cole tucker
off to left hit it just
softly enough two are going to score
and cole tucker comes through with a two
run
two strike two out hit bucks up six to
two
that's a beautiful thing just putting
the ball in play
tied up jam shot fastball reading on the
on the hands
[Applause]
strike three call perfectly placed by
rodriguez
he strikes out three in the inning and
the pirates take one for the cubs a
nice win here this afternoon yes it was
and congratulations jt brubacher
congratulations brian reynolds